to Detroit you know the way we perceive  knowledge understanding is not just  information right it depends on your  level of being means level of soul  embodiment solid individualization and  it relates to for example what good  you've talked about the tried of  knowledge being and understanding right  and it's all interrelated and people  think the more knowledge you have the  more understanding you have which is not  true because if you knowledge is not  matched up of being with embodiment it  just results in information like  intellectual masturbation but not true  understanding which is wisdom so it goes  hand in hand well we're talking about  that the other day yeah we were